There's an important
distinction to make
between cause and
effect when analyzing
the motion of objects.
There are two very separate
questions that we can ask.
The first is, how does a
particular object move?
This is a purely descriptive
geometrical question
that we're asking.
What does the geometry
of the motion look like?
If we were to draw
its trajectory
as a function of time, what's
the shape of that trajectory?
The study of the geometry
of motion of a trajectory
is referred to as kinematics.
The second question we can
ask is, why does an object
move the way it does?
Why does the kinematic
description of the trajectory
look the way it does?
This concerns what the
causes are of the motion
and of the changes
in that motion.
The study of the cause
behind the changes of motion
is called dynamics.
Newton's Second Law of Motion
connects these two questions.
When we write F equals
ma, this is more than just
a mathematical identity.
Physically, we're connecting
two very different questions.
And we can symbolize that
by dividing the equation
into its two sides.
The right-hand
side, the ma side,
is essentially asking
the question of how, how
does the object move?
What does that motion look like?
It's a description, a
geometric description
of the object's motion.
The left-hand side of the
equation, where the forces are,
answers the question of
why, why does the object
move the way it does?
What causes the
motion to change?
These are very
different conceptually.
And the remarkable thing about
Newton's Second Law, in fact,
one of Newton's
signature accomplishments
was to realize that
these two questions can
be connected in this way through
Newton's Second Law of Motion.
Since these are very
different issues,
we'll examine them
separately in our course.
We'll begin this week by looking
at kinematics in one and two
dimensions, basically
learning how
to describe the geometric
motion of an object
and its trajectory.
We'll follow that by discussing
the dynamics of the motion,
examining why an object's motion
changes when forces are applied
through a discussion of Newton's
laws and their applications.